all right freeway's in really good shape  as you're getting rolling here on your  Wednesday morning no crashes to report  we have been checking in for months now  on the I-15 Tropicana rebuild project  talking about Lane restrictions off and  on in both directions but the focus now  is turning to Tropicana itself because  next month the Nevada Department of  Transportation is literally going to  destroy Tropicana over the I-15 not the  entire Bridge they're going to do half  of it and they're going to start with  the westbound side which is on the  Northern section of the Beltway of the  uh of Tropicana over the freeway so  here's some of the heavy equipment  hanging out there they have taken away a  couple of lanes from you it looks like  they're giving them back at least you  have a couple to get through so this is  just a little bit of what's in store on  the Tropicana I-15 rebuild project put  that in the back your mind John